[Music]
with every rocket we launch into the
Earth's orbit we're trapping ourselves
on our own planet
how could sending rockets into space put
an end to space exploration and how
dangerous would it be to get stuck here
with all the space debris floating above
our hands this is what if and here's
what would happen if we trashed Earth's
orbit with space junk almost everything
that we've launched into space ends up
either falling down and burning up in
the atmosphere or getting caught in the
Earth's lower orbit for thousands of
years the Earth's lower orbit is
surrounded by just 200 kilograms of
small rocky debris in the form of
meteoroids but it's also got a belt of
about three million kilograms of space
junk 20,000 pieces of debris as large as
a softball 500,000 pieces larger than a
marble and many millions of pieces of
debris too small to track are orbiting
the earth what makes these floating
parts of old satellites and spent rocket
bodies so dangerous it's the speed they
move at this junk is hurtling through
space at a speed of 8 km/s at that speed
one small bolt is enough to shatter a
working satellite into hundreds of
pieces but it's what comes next that
could hold off our dreams of building
moon bases colonizing Mars and any space
exploration whatsoever the more junk we
leave uncontrolled in the Earth's lower
orbit the harder it is not to get hit by
it
things are running into each other
fragments of debris are colliding and
breaking up multiplying the number of
items flying through the space junkyard
and they're hitting working spacecraft
to one day that could hit enough
satellites to initiate an unstoppable
destructive chain reaction the Kessler
syndrome the cascade of collisions would
make our lower orbit so congested with
man-made debris that eventually there
would be no active spacecraft left
everything in the Earth's orbit would be
turned into a deadly wall of celestial
scrap near-earth space would become
unusable no Rockets could be safely
launched until we clean up the orbit
we'd have to put our space missions on
pause and we'd be trapped on the planet
for generations what would it be like
down here
well the debris belt wouldn't rain down
on earth and caused massive destruction
space rubbish would disintegrate in the
atmosphere before it reached our
planet's surface but the collisions
would produce a lot of dust that dust
illuminated by sunlight would cause an
ever-present Twilight on the planet with
this kind of light pollution you'd
forget what nights used to look like
what's even more unpleasant all of our
satellite networks would go down
there'd be no satellite communications
no GPS navigation no weather data and no
way to do any Science in the Earth's
orbit you'd have to go back to paper
maps and get your cash out
welcome to the 1970s on a positive note
science has already come up with a few
ideas for cleaning up our lower orbit
mess they're looking at capturing the
space debris with a net or harpoon or
vaporizing the small bits of junk with
lasers
whatever action we deployed we should
act quick if we want to launch humanity
on far space missions and finally
colonize that red planet but that's a
story for another what if
[Music]